you
so let's see what we could do nearly 50
players in this one it's been a while
maybe this will be a shaking shaking out
for the rust john madden is in here I
see Aaron's recce
I don't think no I don't think we've
ever played before we're gonna play now
though okay 50 players is where we are
at c5 no matter what let's break up the
center and get some free moves in maybe
I could get d5 in I guess so I have a
check all right maybe we just get rid of
their night yeah let's do this and then
try and play against their dark square
Bishop actually I'm gonna have a very
difficult time mm okay this is very
scary already why would you do this to
your king why would you do this to your
king okay yeah I'm in some hot water
some serious hot water well I'm gonna
get mated what am i doing they have this
square here this is an awful start this
is very painful they're very painful oh
yeah this is no good okay well we're
gonna try to go fast it's not going to
work though the only thing I liked about
this game is my speed but I'm down a
piece what good is that what good is
that um here I guess this was awful
awful
I could resign and probably should yeah
let's just resign this and start over
not the tournament but yeah we're not
gonna rage quit a tournament return
we're gonna return to turn right back
determine okay yeah Bishop e3 and that
the no soup for you move I'm still in it
I'm just not getting paired up yeah that
was the move that said no not so fast
buddy
you can't Castle and complete your
development we're going to soldier on
we're not going to let that scare us
away from playing well hang on let's
take care damage their structure what's
the story all right we're gonna take
here and then defend efore they're gonna
damage my structure not anymore
oh don't like how I'm playing okay is
this gonna hurt me
maybe oh that's a freebie oh boy
tricky Knights okay
let's provide a gap for my king get
Knight c4 in there a bit scary for sure
play Knight takes pawn they have this
here not feeling too good about this
position I have a material plus I'm a
threatening b5 now oh they had that dah
what a terrible mouth slip oh I gotta go
for time really no good man no good this
is as good as resigning this move that
was a terrible move rook to d7 I have a
tricky Knight though it's about it
that's about it I'm dropping everything
I'm dropping everything
have to resign again oh no you can't win
a tournament if you lose your first two
games okay um we're gonna have to shake
another one off I guess oh man okay
regroup somehow all right that wasn't a
cool no slip Rick to d7 mmm
even before that though I was implying
too good before the mouse slip okay yeah
let's not start out with Knight f3 I'm
gonna have to start killing opponents
soon or at least try to because oh my
goodness what did I just do that
he's uh he's feeling bad for me he's
feeling very bad for me yeah a free
knight on e4 and now this
I have no what's going on no explanation
yeah I should just shut up shut up and
play a game without commentating for
once would you I was ready to move my
epon oh my goodness it's been too long
man it's been too long for a tournament
hmm get all your pieces working would
you man all of them stop trying to throw
me in a pin I am done dancing enough
with the dancing get castled and I'm not
quite sure what this is doing I'll snip
up on let's throw in a check just for
fun I'm happy about that
throw your queen in the center and let
her be a pest maybe look for this break
although they have this advance let's
back up now this I think they would have
c3 there's nothing exciting happening on
h7 is they're smashing through on d3
maybe Bishop takes pawn if the rook goes
somewhere like right now and then he's a
super defender just backup a bishop
somewhere yeah right here on take snacks
he's a he's an animal keep him here I'll
just take like this just in case uh
let's move him I guess it's diagonals
open but shouldn't be a problem Rick f5
let's just go here seventh rank incoming
I have a huge time edge huge push next
if check oh it's a freebie here got a
queen take advantage of the pin we got
this okay back to charming
are we on time or are we on the first
page no we're not okay 23 minutes remain
shake it off man shake it off I'll be
doing with the stream any comcast gamuts
no no technical issues wonderful we're
still alive we're still alive and I'm
still somehow starting out with tonight
f3 let's take like this open a door for
my Oh take care Queen exchange and what
now be a pest with my Knights let's back
up let's back up take on b7 if they take
this guy out develop keep developing
take here as an in-betweener and then
the recapture and here maybe no matter
what probably do that no matter what
right throw this
in here I get my LightSquared bishop
working and they're gonna go pawn
hunting maybe let's try and pick up the
light square bishop well I could take on
a seven wits check you have a problem is
there some problem that you're not doing
that take with the pawn
he's a passer my knight needs to
reposition mm-hmm let's get him here
maybe insert this check huge time edge
let's do this
actually let's trade nights okay this is
I'm trying to remove that block hater
could take the night maybe snip this
pawn mm-hmm let's just back up all night
here is pretty good although I'll take
on b7 let's do this it's getting more
complicated than I would like maybe I
could weave a mating net
actually it's throwing a check and let's
take here and come down with a pin that
should do it
pretty big-time edge as well threatening
threatening mate here that is me back to
tournament I think it was me or maybe
they lost on time one of the two I
couldn't see at the end okay 20 less
than 21 minutes remain
it's still not on the front page I got
to do battle with this beast again
hopefully his dark square bishop does
not turn into an animal hopefully I
don't allow his dark square bishop to
turn into an animal this one let's
repeat I was four oh it's hanging under
the Queen and I'm not quite sure I want
to play this right away let's do it now
let's do this oh you're gonna do that
really okay hmm let's see if I could get
some compensation okay yeah I definitely
will have compensation here it's
throwing this first yeah I like this
position now yeah I definitely like this
position
gonna get to the seventh and yeah let's
do this
he's still an animal it's still really
strong look here and the rook has to be
very careful let's get my King working I
had this move I should have done it
sooner I'm gonna throw this in just for
a king position hmm guys have to take
now I like my rook too much he's doing
very good things hmm
that seemed like a mistake I'm just
going to take give a check and then take
care hmm let's just grab on okay I don't
like how I'm playing this let's push
here keep pushing okay let's give a
check that was really foolish what I
just did here oh I had such a good
position man I have to resign how did I
allow that to happen how did I allow
that to happen
you know what their king I should have
moved my king to d5 before his King got
to c4 mmm before his king got to c4 I
should have played King 2d for his king
position was too good in that one okay
improving improving my skill all right
let's try and build in the center kick
him away all right all right so I have a
space advantage I'm gonna challenge this
a five square so we'll play f4 first
castle it's good to take it see how they
recapture night into f5 probably he's
going to be a tremendous pest let's get
him in here Queen g5 very strong post
Knight takes h6
go for it oh yeah actually cuz I could
come back here and block my bishop on d3
could do something else
um let's go here pon takes I have this
and it's mate mm-hmm
still the same sort of still the same
story if pawn takes Knight and I'm
threatening mate now all right all right
so this is collapsing let's check and we
got mate happening soon
there we go mate back to term 17 minutes
remain we're not quite at the halfway
point I'm at 10 I have no idea who's in
first first is at 21 okay plenty of
plenty of time left let's see let's try
Knight of 6 I guess okay I might have to
do some cheap tactics like like an early
night g4 pinpointing f2 you know that
kind of stuff
it might already be that at that point
in the game all right
I'm just gonna play this one where that
pawn acts as a thorn or at least tries
to grab some space here and Ike takes I
take with the pawn okay what are they
doing now Bishop here this is a very
difficult pin mm I guess try to get my
knight here I don't want to take okay I
want to play f5 and take advantage of
the pin okay let's open this up I'm rook
take so I'm prepared to get the other
rook to Fe I'm very tempted to sack my
Queen Queen f6 okay let's go here and
defend this square here I guess to watch
out for a night there all right I Knight
needs to be doing something else let's
try this
his kings in the center I'm gonna take
with the Queen a knight
oh I didn't see that mouth
all right let's take care and we're
gonna get this in soon hopefully Wow no
kayo this is big trouble the Queen's are
gonna be off I man oh they could have
taken here I guess they didn't see it
I've assumed Nami of pawns in the center
tsunami and okay so I'm gonna win on
time with this one queen well positioned
now but yeah I was completely busted
they're down on time back to tournament
okay and I think I saw something just a
glitch up there with my computer it's
not cool all right let's try to get in
d5 I guess and see five let's challenge
the center okay so my light square
bishop could come out and pin the night
maybe I go for a structural shift like
okay they wasted some time here so I'm
gonna shoot for man I'm getting I'm
getting some I'm having some computer
issues here not cool
I didn't mean to do that rip to see a
was better rookie aide is fine uh let's
get a flight square 94 on takes yeah
they're not quite sure what to do me
neither
I could relate not quite sure okay they
have to take what their night now my
night should be really good on this
square f2 has pressure on it wanna play
rip to c8 soon maybe back my bishop up
and look for mate that's maybe an idea
how do they defend they don't defend h2
I have to shoot for h2 okay well the top
guy has a speed bump as well at the very
end 23 is top I have 16 hmm alright oh I
got this guy again I got to get him back
I definitely have to get him back okay
she's back ooh what's that about that
must have been a mouse slip
unless he's taunting me am I being set
for taunting my being talked to should
this guy be flagged for taunting
taunting team black yeah its football
season you know what I mean
Knights e5 it's a juicy square man
all right let's expand beam expander no
idea what that means man no idea all
right
each file is where you belong let's keep
a grip over this square over here
let's bring the pain bring the pain
they're gonna push here rook right here
and shouldn't it be collapsing and
pretty sure it's collapsing now right
Rick takes here we got mating stuff I
can't win this I'm gonna be very upset
very upset yeah
let's break it down let's crash through
with the piece with a piece Oh let's
maneuver my knight to f6 and they're
stopping that um let's get my king over
here I'm getting a little scared to be
honest a little scared
uh-huh it's too scary too scary they're
down on time oh and they're doing that
move okay get my King in okay oh they
have a passed pawn I didn't realize
don't get made it whatever happens I got
their queen man just got gonna run out
of time any time soon
please finally oh my goodness I had to
go down to that are you serious oh my
goodness
wow you had an attack and a half an
attack and a half on the h-file and you
had to let it get down to like two
seconds a rat race a time race shame on
you man shame on you ah
unbelievable unbelievable
oh I don't know I don't have answers I
hope you're not here looking for answers
because there's none there's none
available none available no reason you
know it's just how it is
oh what's that move about okay
um they're hitting my Bishop do you see
that do you see that okay we have a
two-to-one majority on the Queen side
now what are you going to do with it
what are you gonna do if they hit them
where they're weak hit them where they
are weak I'm not quite sure where
they're weak f2 they're weak there we go
Bishop takes pawn as well it's too good
not to do man it's too good not to do
just do it just do it right
rook takes g3 is not available all right
I might be okay with this actually I'm
gonna take okay I have three am I trying
to say I have three pawns for the piece
I'm down on time let's see what they do
here okay over here and then keep
pushing my palm keep pushing
rook activity gain a tempo against the
bishop get a pawn roller going over here
all right got this guy going oh I should
have dropped that guy you know he was a
pretty important and Oh fortunately I
have a fork fortunately I have a fork
okay and I'm gonna Queen very soon how's
the clock situation let's just make this
really clean and
free move so you don't lose any time
keep going don't drop your queen don't
drop your queen back determine oh man
how am I in fourth not anymore I'm in
fifth 33 28 28 27 I'm at 24 8 minutes
remaining
oh I'm surprised I'm even this close I
guess uh no one else is squeaky clean
here at a goose egg goose egg
all right oh look out it's a 5 is
someone on tilt all of a sudden they've
done too much dancing they've wasted too
much time let's open the position up
let's try and punish my opponent for
this kind of play that's a freebie or
maybe not they're gonna push I want to
take here I'm on their queen they get
the piece back but I'm still up some
material maybe I shouldn't allow this
damaging in the structure let's go
forward kick their night around not
quite sure what this is doing a six
would have been better a six and B five
all right he's a passer let's see if I
could make some magic happen I'm gonna
be the a foul they gave me the a file
threatening mate threatening to mate
again and this is unavoidable soon that
is game back to tournament 33 28 28 I'm
in third how much time is left plenty
less than seven let's try I don't know
this stuff no no no no no no mouse slips
man let's pin this guy maybe play
against a bad structure you take my
knight okay I'll take here keep the
Queens on the board Knight c4 is a nice
square yeah let's do this
and develop what's tempo to be careful
of a fork here well it's just defend
like that play simply fish up here no
pressure here how they castling Queen f4
keep the Knights on the board
f7 now keep the bishop on the board be a
pest be a pest focus on the dark squares
Castle I take the rook
on the rock I'm right oh I have mate
mate is better than threatening the rook
in the corner back to tournament
38:32 less than six minutes remain
okay I got some fire here I'm on fire a
little bit
I got a flame right next to my number
there and for some reason I'm playing
something quiet solid but quiet with the
pitcher of f4 let's hit that b7 um yeah
I might end up sacking my clean clean
for two rooks what are they doing they
resigned that's beautiful
I love the quick resign I think they
could have castled Queen c7 and then
after they moved the night they would
have gotten my queen back alright this
guy again
who ran around like crazy with this King
night he was excited about converting
his uh his King Knight into a queen
knight in that game than the last game
we played Bishop g4 let's get out of
this soon maybe I'm on b7
let's Castle queenside I like that idea
that's like my light square bishop be a
pest let's take what the rook so I'm
prepared to now double just back up back
up maybe move forward let's think about
moving forward next time huh can I move
forward first okay double let's just
blunt that diagonal okay
heavy piece ending control the only open
file it's important king ending I'm not
quite sure who's better in a king ending
uh-huh never the Queen's off I guess so
no I should have gotten to the seventh
okay and we're gonna try this ending can
I get an outside pass sure if they take
it's bad I should have played my king up
sooner okay let's maintain a king
position hmm okay
King here and then an outside passer
yeah there should be one now for me
those tricks don't work in this position
as my king is in a good spot so this is
a one King and pawn ending now okay
let's go with this guy he can't be
caught
yeah let's push the other one fast oh
are you kidding me
that was almost stalemate that was
almost stalemate
don't fall for stalemate man it's not
stalemate they have a pawn move it's
really close and my my time was really
low - I'm in first
well three minutes call it's free
minutes remaining I'm on fire this guy
is not forty thirty I gotta get this one
forty or forty two thirty eight okay uh
let's go Bishop here and break in the
center line up maybe they can't castle
maybe my queen is gonna be a beast still
can't castle let's go here
throw rook on the D file and then yeah
okay um let's get rid of their strong
Bishop and yeah it's the scoop here okay
forks forks a threatening night here
they might push their pawn Knight e3
this is a strong move actually a winning
move I might say 94 is maybe the only
defense there in the think tank I love
it I love when my opponent goes into
think tank oh this wasn't best oh okay I
think the King needed to go somewhere
else now I got the exchange
let's open up files I have an extra rope
he needs files to work with let's open a
file
Knight there's pretty good huh all right
well at least I could pinpoint the
knight now and then get it C or yeah
that's seats
right learn your coordinates man learn
them okay we got a check we're looking
for mates where's the mate is it
happening soon let's just take some
material let's just take that pond a
huge time edge hitting the night hitting
the night again watch out he is super
tricky let's just simplify they don't
have much time
crawl up into a ball they're down on
time back to China where do we stand one
minutes ago 44 41 and he is not on
streak mode so even if he gets a win I
don't think I could be caught about this
guy maybe he's resorting if he's berserk
he could catch me if he wins am I gonna
get paired up again Oh John Madden okay
this is one that will likely only count
for raiding but not for the tournament
okay
I'm gonna gain another tempo well not
another but I'm going to gain a tempo
eventually against their Queen peace
improvement rook to e1 there haha what
are you doing to beat out man trying to
hurt me on each - oh it's opening it up
Oh
let's go here don't you dare try to do
that oh how they moved and you would see
they moved okay and it's getting a
little too scary for me yeah I don't
like it I want to get rid of their
Knight as soon as possible
Queen f3 yeah they're Knight he's still
around and he's scary let's go here I
guess the pawn push I to get this
in-betweener I have d3 open now to get
rid of this guy yeah let's just take
here which one you're gonna go for all
right he lives
this is hit I'll just get off the
exchange I'm fine with this
it's a tremendous thorn this pawn here
threatening mates I imagine with Queen
takes and then getting here can't be
avoided really can't it
that's mate next I get first oh my
goodness
tournament is over I would not have
guessed that no way not with that kind
of a start
goose a goose egg a few games and
another goose egg and then I finally got
into some rhythm but man oh wow
it's been a while then a while good
games to all who played 50 were at the
start and at the end 81 of you were
playing all right GG's to the 81 of you
you